you talk about playing the game
quote-unquote to win but what about
people that play the game to win for
themselves
and how do I defeat them that's a good
good question and it hit me yeah when I
saw that question
ooh that's a good point and that's a
good there's a very important
distinction there because I'm always
saying play the game yeah hey you gotta
play the game you gotta you gotta build
the relationships with the boss
you gotta learn what they like and kind
of tow the party line you kind of do the
little things you gotta support the
corporate headquarters or the boss or
the man right or whatever entity is up
in that ivory tower I want you to play
the game get them on your side and the
reason I say to do those things is that
so you can get more control so that
people ask your opinion so that you get
listened to so that perhaps you get
promoted which is good but the reason
you're doing all those things the reason
that you're playing the game is to help
your team accomplish the mission that's
what you are trying to do it's to help
your team accomplish the mission now the
the other side of that is what this
question is about people that are
playing the game for personal gain they
they play the game so that they can get
listened to so they can drive their
personal agenda so they so they can get
promoted and they want to get promoted
so they can abuse their power and maybe
that abuse of power is just is just
working less maybe it's making other
people do through crap jobs or whatever
that whatever the case may be but
they've got an agenda and they're gonna
try and get promoted so they can take
care of themselves and that is not why I
tell you to play the game and that's not
why I played the game and I definitely
played the game and I played to win but
I played because I wanted my squad or my
platoon or
tasks unit or my training command to be
able to better accomplish our mission
that's why I played the game now there
is a secondary benefit of playing the
game and that is that you could possibly
get promoted earlier you could get
praise from the boss that looks good on
your record and all those things can
happen when you're playing the game but
that's just like collateral sort of
fringe benefits but that's not why
you're playing the game you play the
game to help the team win and when the
team wins you win which also makes the
team win again so it's like a positive
cycle because you start developing a
good reputation now you get more leeway
from the boss in a more leeway you get
from the boss the more you have the
ability to make maneuvers on the
battlefield the more you can maneuver on
the battlefield the more offensive you
could be the more offensive you could be
the more you win and then you get more
ability to move more because your boss
is giving you even more room to maneuver
so it's a it's a cycle it's a good
positive cycle now when you have someone
that's on the team that's playing the
game for themselves first of all no one
likes that person right everyone can see
that person no one likes them and
there's believe me the military the
military has unbelievable people that
play the game for the best possible
reasons to help their platoon and help
the mission and help succeed there's
also plenty of people in the military
and in every every different line of
work there's plenty of people that play
the game because they want to they want
them they want they're looking out for
themselves looking out from number one
right I'm noting expressions they're
looking out for number one there's
plenty of people and I dealt with people
like that all the time and what did I do
I used the to my advantage and I'll tell
you what I would get in their head and
what I would do is I would make them
think that the best way for them to win
for themselves personally was for the
team to win I would get that into their
head because a lot of times they missed
that point they're looking out for
themselves they're not worried about the
team and I would get them thinking that
they're gonna look the best if the team
wins hey if you really want to look
the best way you can get promoted is if
we look good you know if the team does
great if you get us the gear we want the
equipment we want their training that we
need that's the best way you're gonna
look awesome because we're gonna succeed
more and that's gonna make you look good
mmm and I'm of course I'm gonna be more
tactful that I'm not saying it like that
but I'm saying it right don't get my
word getting them get the messaging is
they're gonna be saying things hey you
know our boss doesn't like our boss
doesn't like leaders that complain right
you know until the boss he doesn't like
complainers you know I mean little
little things like that right hey the
possibly boss likes to hear the truth
about stuff he wants to know what you
know what I mean little things like that
and you know here's the thing that
person that person might get the
promotion because what you've done is
you've helped them act correctly
actually and there's a chance a decent
chance a good chance even that they
carry that forward they realize that hey
the best way to play the game is to help
the team and the best way to look good
is to help Dead's is to make the team
good and succeed at the mission hmm
and it's really well you know one of the
classic cases then we'll get into
ownership a little bit but if something
goes wrong right the person that's
looking out for themselves blames
everyone else mmm and and so that's a
challenge right because once you start
blaming once that boss starts blaming
everyone then the whole team starts
blaming each other so how do you fix
that well we've talked about so million
times you step up and say hey you know
boss is my fault and boss that's right
it's your fault and there's a there's a
good chance that they recognize how
positive that is mmm and it may take a
while and it may never happen because
some people are just savages right some
people are just complete they only care
about themselves they only care about
the next promotion and getting the next
award and getting the next bit of
recognition there's people like that
there's they're horrible they're
horrible they exist but they're pretty
small most people if they see hey this
this is working for this guy
it can work for me too and that starts
to spread and the other thing that
happens I think is if someone's a just a
flagrant self promoter mm-hmm that you
might get them one promotion because you
were there to kind of make them look
good but the next time around they're
gonna get seen they're gonna get found
out they're gonna people are gonna
realize what kind of person they are and
that's that's where it catches up with
them so you keep playing the game you
keep you keep working hard don't worry
about them and actually do your best to
help them out the person that's like
self promoting do your best to help them
out and if they're the boss make them
look good I always want to make my boss
look good yeah yeah it's gonna help you
in the long run yeah it hurts sometimes
yeah it's hard to do sometimes yeah our
ego gets in the way sometimes okay put
that ego in check because what's more
important because if you're my boss echo
and you're doing this just to make
yourself look good if I then undermine
you well and now we don't accomplish the
mission as well I'm actually a bad
person because I didn't do my best to
accomplish the mission mmm right we
didn't look good yeah I'm not worried
about how we look but we failed in our
mission oh we didn't do our mission to
the best of our ability so now I'm not
gonna let that happen
you want to look great cool I want to
make you look great because I want us to
look great doing our mission because
that's what's important to me yeah and
if some of the collateral damage of that
is that you look great even though
you're a jerk and I get you promoted
that's okay because eventually you're
gonna get found out or you're gonna
learn to be a better person
and to support the team and that's how
you got promoted and you're gonna
realize that you'll become a good leader
yeah yeah I agree with that when well
like I always have where people can see
that too you know they can see yeah you
know like if your boss is like a
self-promoter or whatever and you have
it in your head I understand I
understand this because I've been in a
situation where I'm like shoot I kind of
feel inside like I don't want to like
make an effort to make them look good
kind of thing because it's like he
doesn't deserve it and
thing and what like what I'm gonna make
him looking and now everyone's gonna
think that he looks good kind of thing
but then when you really think about it
now they're not yeah you're right and
the same goes for you like if you if
you're like to you know if you're just
focusing on the positive stuff you know
you know how like you're what do you
listen you know if you don't have
anything nice to say don't say it at all
if you're really doing that like people
noticed that too like that guy is like
really positive good idea focusing like
this you know kind of thing like people
see it and this doesn't mean you're just
mr. positive sugarcoat and everything
and no it's not what I'm talking about
that but you are not focusing on the
negative instead of saying oh we're all
about this you say you know what we got
some deficiencies here here's what I'm
gonna do to fix them yeah yeah how
simple is that
just get better yeah the point is people
they see they see don't think that you
know like you're gonna help you know
make this guy look good in their just
good they're gonna not see it and
they're just gonna fall for the trick or
science badly see that most of the time
it's that example that you said about
playing to their ego or whatever where
you're like hey you know you you're
gonna look really good if so you ever
seen the movie Moana I saw three minutes
of it ah see there you go she does excel
the guy the main guys near the demigod
name is Molly I'm played by the rock by
the way
Dwayne Johnson great movie by the way um
she does him like that she's like hey
let's they got to go do this mission you
know restore the heart you know whatever
it's long story but and he's like you
know whatever reluctant and he's like
she's like hey you'll be a hero
again and he's like I'm already a hero
just like wow no not for a while you
know you haven't done anything lately
but if you do this and you'll be the
hero to everyone and yeah any you know
of course he does it of course be a man
it's good to get a quick example it
works there it is proof on on Mon